It has been estimated that as much as 95
percent of the world’s data will never be
seen by human eyes. Much of this unseen data
is called M to M data or machine to machine.
There are many sources of machine generated data.
Examples include, when the cell phones ping
to the cell towers to check where they are,
when the satellite radio and the GPS connect
to locate the car or your phone, the RFID or
radio frequency identification tag readings
on billions of small objects, readings from
medical devices and web crawlers and spam bots.
Perhaps the most interesting part of the machine
to machine communications falls under the rubric
of the Internet of Things. It is estimated that by
2025, as many as 30 billion uniquely identifiable
devices may be connected to the internet.
This actually requires a major change in how
the internet works. Basically, everything will
have a chip and it will be connected to the
internet and they’ll be talking to each other,
sharing information. So when you hear people talk
about smart sensors, in your home or in your city
or on your air conditioning or the smart home,
which knows when to turn lights on or change
the temperature, or the smart grids where the
city generates and sends out the electricity,
or the smart city itself which coordinates all
of the traffic and the utilities as a way of
being more efficient and more economical in
providing better service. All of this would
be enabled by small objects communicating
one with another in the internet of things.
Some of the uses for this can include putting
sensors on production lines to monitor systems for
when they need maintenance, or the smart meters
on utility systems to shut them off at peak times.
Also things like infrastructure management, that
talks about control and monitoring of bridges,
railways, wind farms, traffic systems. Industrial
applications like manufacturing process controls,
supply chain network, having predictive
maintenance or integration with a smart grid
to optimize energy consumption. There is energy
management, that’s the switches and outlets and
bulbs and TVs and screens and heating systems,
controlling ovens, changing lighting conditions.
And then, medical and healthcare systems.
Basically, anything that’s mechanical can be
eventually hooked up and communicating through
the internet of things. All of which generates
an enormous amount of data as they talk one to
another and coordinate their own activities. So,
in looking at the differences between machine
generated data and human generated data, the
most obvious difference is that all of the
machine generated data is machine readable. It
can be immediately searched and read and mined.
It’s high on volume and velocity, two
of the characteristics of big data,
but low on variety, which makes it
easier for machines to deal with it.